[Music]
ea invited several media outlets as well
as a bunch of battlefield content
creators to dive into the battlefield
2042 beta so while those of you excited
to play are getting ready to sink your
teeth into the beta for the first time
here's a breakdown of what you can
expect to see and our first impressions
and honestly for the most part it's
pretty good battlefield 2042 comes out
real soon so if you want to stay in the
know be sure to subscribe to this
channel like this video and hit that
bell button it's free let's dive in
the build that we had access to was the
all-out warfare conquest mode on the
orbital map you might remember that map
from the trailers because it's the one
with that giant rocket about to launch
as a kind of levolution throughout each
match the only thing that stood out to
me is something that might be a
different experience than what we could
obviously expect in the retail build was
the fact that i was unable to zoom in on
the map during the gameplay but
everything else seemed pretty par for
the course also in the matches that i
was able to load into there were a lot
of ai bots
like
a lot and all i'll say on that for now
is that they weren't like the
spartanbots from the halo infinite tech
preview but more on that in just a bit
so what was the beta like the short
answer is fun the combat felt snappy
with adrenaline-fueled firefights
returning to a pretty fast ttk in
battlefield made me feel really powerful
and combining the freestyle loadouts
with the new specialist made me curious
to experiment before we dive into the
specialists which are a huge part of
2042's identity it is worth talking
about the core gameplay loop and where
2042 fits on the spectrum of giving that
battlefield feel the core gameplay loop
is strong we started out with limited
weapons but with enough usage kills xp
gains and ribbons earned other weapons
were unlocked within that class now i'm
mainly stuck to my tried and true
assault rifle simply swapping from full
auto to single shots or burst fire on a
situational basis the gun play was fun
and any fire fight that i had win or
lose was a thrilling moment for me the
gameplay was sullied a bit though thanks
to the ai bots which in some matches
were just everywhere making me wonder
where all the real players were at there
were some matchmaking issues during our
hands-on time so it probably was more of
the fact that other players couldn't
load in which is why the game just kept
filling it up with bots and the bots
were as i'm sure you guessed it a joke
unfortunately the first multi-kill i got
against them was awesome yeah but by the
end of that three hour play session that
we had i was over the bots they were
just too easy they stood still on
ladders like idiots or didn't do any
kind of evasive maneuvering they just
like foreheaded the w key half the time
the entire way i'd be lying if i said i
didn't die to a bot a couple of times
but
i just whatever shut up i had my reasons
the vehicles were plentiful as well but
weren't to my liking as much mainly
because it felt like the handling was
still somewhat unpolished or i didn't
spend enough time tweaking the
sensitivity settings on pc i'm sure
controller players may have had an
easier time navigating but most vehicles
for me felt a little unwieldy on the
terrain with camera angles sometimes
even hitching or clipping that we can
safely chalk up to it being more of a
consequence of the beta build rather
than how vehicles will actually handle
at launch but that being said you'd
better get used to vehicles even if
you're usually on foot because these
maps man they're huge we only played
orbital which isn't even supposed to be
the largest map but that was still
really big especially because firefights
are now condensed into sectors and
clusters it is not uncommon to clear a
squad off of an objective and then
realize that all the firefights are on
the complete other side of the map
thankfully though 2042 has a new vehicle
call-in system which i forgot about
honestly until the final hour of the
beta the few times i used it it was
surprisingly intuitive you pick from a
menu what kind of vehicle you want
anywhere from the boston dynamics dog
known as ranger to a full-on tank which
will then be parachuted down to your
location there is a cooldown so you
can't just spam the vehicles willy-nilly
but it definitely felt nice to remember
that there was an easy solution to
getting out of no man's land if you
didn't want to spend that time on foot
more time with this system we'll flesh
out details and answer questions such as
how often can a player spam the call in
system or if there are any restrictions
if too many members of your squad try to
use it at the same time my guess is
since all of this is so new it wasn't
really being used as often which would
explain why any time that i needed a
vehicle i had no issue getting access to
one speaking of quality of life changes
the new attachment system is incredible
you essentially bring up a hud that will
let you adjust your gun's barrel handle
or even scope all on the fly it took me
some time to get used to it but i don't
know how we ever lived without it we're
gonna learn more once the open beta hits
and we reach launch day so specifics
like how to pick specific attachments in
certain slots on the interface will
become more apparent in the future for
now though i worked with what
attachments the interface already had
and it was pretty solid my favorite
tactic was using the attachments
favoring close quarter combat and then
after i would zipline my way up the
skyscraper swapping to longer sights to
get a better angle and scout ahead on
enemies further away from my squad the
versatility offered by this new system
is genuinely awesome and will only be
improved as the game launches since
there have been a lot of breakdowns
recently on the new specialist system
from dice now is also a good time to
break down how those specialists felt in
practice it is no secret that
battlefield tends to be unbalanced for
better or worse and the specialist
system is gonna be no exception
specialists main draws are intrinsic
traits and abilities that separate them
from the rest of the pack and in the
beta we had the option to play as mckay
boris falk and casper the reason these
specialists feel like they could
dramatically shift the sandbox is that
with abilities you were basically
creating a hero system like overwatch or
apex legends and that means a new
dynamic to the meta you're not only
thinking about weapons anymore but how
each weapon now pairs with an ability
this is not a bad thing i actually
really like the system a lot despite the
potential balance issues because the
more factors that weigh into a build the
more meaningful the build feels and
right now specialists feel pretty
meaningful in very subtle ways i mostly
played in the k despite getting some
assist kills with boris's deployable
turret and trying to remember that i
could instant heal myself with falx's
medic syringe casper unfortunately i
didn't do much besides glitch his spy
drone into the ground but mckay man that
is my guy mckay's intrinsic ability is
that he can move faster when he is
aiming weapons as well as traveling
faster across zip lines which is really
cool i am partial to mobility type
heroes and classes so mckay felt really
good to work with i tried messing with
this grapple hook ability to mix results
but i know folks out there will have
some awesome highlight reels using it
that being said the grapple hook is
strong letting you scale certain heights
and reduce travel time up larger
buildings or you can quickly get out of
a choke point into an advantageous
position and lastly you know i have to
talk about that rocket launch pad
levolution and those damn tornadoes the
short of it is that the tornadoes were
super cool like hilariously awesome to
see in practice
it was weird because i couldn't see my
head or get an angle on anyone and it
was just chaos but also i didn't care i
just saw the tornado and i sprinted as
fast as i possibly could to try and get
swept up by it because it looked fun
which kind of cuts to the heart of
battlefield's character right the chaos
creates this entertainment the tornado
made some good progress across the map
from one sector to the next and i can't
wait to see the other types of extreme
weather such as the desert sandstorms
now the rocket launch felt like a
revolution but also not because there
wasn't any significant map devastation
as far as i could tell there is a way to
destroy the rocket before it launches
which i think has world building story
implications for why the two factions
are fighting on the orbital map in the
first place but ultimately it just had
this like audio timer ticking down most
of the map before it launched it looked
awesome and now i want to see the other
maps levolution style turning points for
sure there is so much more to break down
about the beta such as easter eggs and
guides on how to maximize the specialist
unique talents the beta is open for xbox
game pass ultimate and ea play owners as
well as anyone who pre-ordered the game
for now all you need to really take away
from this vid though is that battlefield
is back and should be a bunch of fun for
everyone i hope you guys enjoyed the
beta and definitely be sure to come back
to this channel in the coming days as
we'll be throwing up a lot more
battlefield 2042 content until next time
[Music]
you